you're enjoying a picnic and
you take a swig of your drink what's
that in your mouth
it's a hornet and you
accidentally swallowed it how
painful is a hornet's sting
[Music]
what happens if you're allergic to its
venom
and could the hornet sting you in your
stomach
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you swallowed a hornet
there are plenty of bugs and insects
that can
bite or sting us and hornets
might be the one that you fear the most
did you know that from the year 2000 to
2017 in the united states the cdc
recorded 1109
deaths from hornet wasp and bee stings
so how likely is it that you could
die from a hornet's sting
you might be asking what's the
difference between a hornet
and a wasp actually there's a huge
obvious difference it's their size
if you've ever seen a hornet they're
much bigger than your common wasp
hornets can grow up to five and a half
centimeters in length although the
average
is about 3.2 centimeters and hornets are
wider than wasps imagine
swallowing that hornets are
actually part of the wasp family they're
a specific type of wasp
but since hornets are bigger than common
wasps
does that make hornets venom more
painful
well they might deliver more venom but
research has shown that the composition
of the venom
is slightly different from wasps and
bees
how painful venom is depends on whether
there's acetylcholine in it
and hornet venom contains acetylcholine
this is why hornet stings tend to hurt
more
they also contain serotonin which acts
as an irritant making the pain even
worse
so turn up that pain dial to 11.
hornets are less aggressive than wasps
but
if a hornet were in your mouth it would
most likely sting you
in self-defense if you're allergic to
hornet stings
what could happen to you well it's not
good news
if you are stung in your mouth or throat
there's a chance that
the area surrounding the sting would
swell up
and if it blocks your airway it could
kill you
if you have a severe allergic reaction
you could go into anaphylactic shock
you could lose consciousness and your
heart could stop beating
but what if by all the wings of fortune
the hornet makes it to your stomach
alive
could it sting you in there our
stomachs are full of acid and enzymes to
break down the food we eat
and the acid is so strong that it
could dissolve most of the other organs
in our bodies
so the hornet would probably have a
pretty tough time staying alive in there
but if it did survive in the stomach
acid
even if it stung you your stomach lining
is so
thick and durable that the sting
might not affect you who knew your
stomach was so tough
okay so what are the chances of this
happening
well it's quite unlikely that you'd
swallow a hornet
either accidentally or on purpose
you might end up biting and chewing the
hornet before you swallowed it but
would you come out of that sting free
well the hornet would probably be
terrified and
since it doesn't lose its stinger you
could be stung
many times hornets are around in the
summer so
when you're outside you might want to
check your glass or your can of soda
before you drink from it
and if you think it would be awful if
you swallowed a hornet imagine
being swallowed by a hippo what would
that feel like
well that's a story for another
what if